[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef and
author who thinks what we eat should
change with the seasons born and raised
in Michigan a bro Behrens was the
daughter of two doctors but they also
lived on and ran a working farm after
college he attended cooking school in
Ireland then back in Michigan ended up
running a farm of her own while also
starting a cooking career now she's the
chef at Greiner farm in Three Oaks
Michigan she's also the author of a
brand-new book roughage a practical
guide to vegetables named a best
cookbook for spring by the New York
Times and Bon Appetit Abra Behrens good
morning thanks for coming all the way
from Michigan and the farm and you
brought the farm with you yeah
thankfully we got a ton of vegetables
going this morning and I'm just it's a
thrill to be here so thank you what's
here so on the first night there we've
got asparagus is just coming into season
so grilled asparagus with roasted
mushrooms smoked whitefish was just huge
for us in Michigan and some pea shoots
over the top perfect green salad all
different farm greens with some garlicky
breadcrumb pan-seared chicken thighs
with mustard braised potatoes and then I
love cottage cheese and so it's a tomato
and cucumber salad over top of a little
bit of really nicely made kind of cheese
my beet dress pasta which is like a
really beautiful color and a way for
people who don't love beets to really
kind of get into it and then over here
we've got a blueberry jam upside-down
cake Berry Farms are a huge amount in
our area and then continuing the
vegetables a beet and gin shrub to drink
which cheers to that thank you so much
now and drink I mentioned that you
growing up you had a farm there that
your parents work that you work but when
was it that you knew food had to be a
part of your life and was that passion
really found you know I yeah my I grew
up on a pickle farm an industrial pickle
farm so my dad's parents were were
farmers and my parents were also both
anesthesiologist so very very busy days
and long days but then we always tried
to eat together and so my mom was an
incredible cook and that really started
it the like wanting to have food be a
part of everything and then in college
you were working at Zingerman's there's
a lot of people know in Ann Arbor and
that took it to a whole different level
yeah so I started cooking at Zingerman's
chef Roger Bowser
really help me get into the food world
and then I was trying to decide what was
next if I was gonna go into the Peace
Corps start working or you maybe take a
chance on cooking school and he said you
should check this place out it's an
Ireland you get to travel it's on a
working farm and it was there that I
really started to think about food as a
place because all of the food that we
were cooking a cooking school was from
their farm to Bali Malou Bali Malou yeah
it's fun to say so take us through that
journey I mean you go to school you end
up going to Chicago but then you end up
back working on the farm yeah so I I
went from cooking school into Chicago my
now husband is in Chicago and so started
cooking around they're really amazing
farm-to-table restaurants but never lost
that idea that I wanted to make food
that was of a place you know that was
representative of that and especially
having grown up in agriculture wanting
to tell the story of the farmers that
are growing this food so we decided to
give it a try and start a farm we farmed
together for about eight years and then
I went back to Chicago because moving a
six hour drive everything like this a
lot so then yeah we went back to Chicago
but I just missed cooking from a piece
of land and trauma growers so when the
opportunity at greener farm came up Katy
Burdette is the the farmer there and she
just grows this amazing produce and so
to get to work with that and show people
what we do is really really powerful
congratulations on making the New York
Times best new cookbook list very
exciting how hard was it to do this I
mean the book was like everything I feel
like it's a lot of work but really good
work it was about a three and a half
year process but I had so many amazing
people contributed to it with the photos
the illustrations and everything so it
was a really fun thing in the wooden
what the Bon Appetit reviewer said it
changed the way she cooked with
vegetables which like I mean isn't that
just like the most amazing thing because
and that's where the name comes from of
the book that this idea of like you
gotta eat your roughage this like
drudgery yeah and I I don't find it to
be that way and so what can I sort of
share in my story of growing the produce
of cooking with it every day that will
hopefully make vegetables kind of the
star of the plate and feel like
something exciting to have and I was
going to say ever when you talked about
making vegetables the star of the plate
what are you doing
differently than just you're not just
cooking them you're from what I
understand using them in other ways
making it fun making it a soup yeah so
and that's the thing is like there's you
know we have a limited number of
vegetables that we can grow in the
northern Midwest but they don't have to
feel redundant even though you're using
the same ones each year so things like
you can have asparagus grilled this way
or shave it really raw and do like a
fresh salad or this beet pasta you can
take that same puree and use it to bind
a risotto or to make a soup or put it on
I love putting it on sandwiches in place
of like mayonnaise or the beet cocktail
I mean if you could have this meal with
anyone past or present who would it be
you know for me cooking is about taking
care of people and giving them a chance
to have a lighter day and I would think
Harriet Tubman's but her whole life
advocating and working for other people
so if I could give her a spot to take
her load off a little bit that would be
my dream fantastic thank you so much
thank you so much for having me and if
you want more on Chef Avro you can join
our website at CBS this morning calm